Speaker 1: So abortion is really the story of
the day. We learned late last night, thanks to
a Politico report, that the Supreme Court plans to
overturn both Roe v Wade and Planned Parenthood v
Casey. And this will essentially do away with
any kind of federal fundamental right to an
abortion in most cases that women have. Marjorie
Taylor GREENE The radical, repugnant Trumpist
congresswoman, made a really wild statement just
a few days ago about abortion. I just haven't had
time to get to it today, but I want to look at
it. This was a comment made before we learned of
the forthcoming Supreme Court decision in which
Marjorie Taylor GREENE raises some really wacky
religious stuff where she says women get abortions
because Satan comes up to them and whispers in
their ear, If you get the abortion, the guy who
impregnated you will marry you. Which of course,
ignores the reality that if you're
pregnant because you've been raped,
I don't know that you want the rapist to marry
you. It's a vile, vile statement, but it shows
us the level of religious delusion that exists
for many of these people. Now, I will say again
earlier when we played the clip of Marjorie Taylor
GREENE crying because she was so happy by the
Supreme Court decision that we learned about.
I said, I think she's nuts. But if you believe
abortion is murder, it's logical. You would be
very happy if abortion is ending. I understand
that this is just unhinged religious nerdery that
is, you know, it's about angels and demons and
ghosts and this type of stuff. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: It's whispered softly and gently
into your ears and into your soul. And he
tells you it's okay. And he says, it's just.
Just this one thing. You're just going to get it
done, get it over with. And then he tells you a
promise. He promises you all these dreams that
you have in your heart. And that's how Satan
sells a sin. And that's how he sells abortion.
He tells a woman that all you have to is you're
just going to go to this clinic, just going to get
it over with, you know? And then you're going to
that guy. He's going to stay with you. That
that boyfriend or the guy, whoever he is,
he's going to marry you, sweep you off your feet.
Speaker 1: So, first of all, this is so specific
that it's extra strange. I'm not saying she's
recounting a personal experience, but it is so
specific that it is very weird. She seems to
have no idea or a concern with the reality
that there are people in all sorts of
situations who make really tough decisions
about what is best for them. And sometimes it has
to do with being a victim of sexual assault rape.
Sometimes it has to do with a fetus with an
abnormality that would prevent ever having
anything close to a normal and fulfilling
life and would be suffering. Sometimes it's
other things. The point is, it ignores. I
mean, this is this is like psych ward stuff
and it ignores the reality of the circumstances
in which sometimes women and families and couples
choose to make really difficult decisions. But
it's also paranormal and bizarre. And one of
the unfortunate things is, you know, earlier I
said, if you believe abortion is murder, it's
logical. You would be happy for it to stop. Okay.
I understand that framework. On the other hand,
if you are making decisions or having opinions
about what civil law should be based on your
evidence, free belief about angel, angels, demons,
demons, ghosts and Satan, it's hard to imagine you
could ever be a productive and reasonable member
of of a legislative body to put it to put it,
quite frankly. And it's extraordinarily
dangerous and it's extraordinarily disturbing